algunas personas utilizan las letras
pau para asegurar que están
multiplicando todos los términos de un
paréntesis por todos los términos del
otro paréntesis usa las letras
pau para multiplicar 3 x + 2 por 5 x
menos 7
entonces lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es recordar qué significa eso de
las letras pau aunque tenemos por aquí p
la p se refiere a los primeros primeros
y una de las asas se refiere a los de
afuera a fuera y la otra a se refiere a
los de adentro a dentro ok y finalmente
la uv se refiere a últimos
y vimos entonces tenemos que usar las
letras pau para multiplicar 3 x 2 por 5
x menos siete que ya no soy un fan de
usar este tipo de mnemotecnia a mí me
gusta mucho más utilizar la propiedad
distributiva dos veces pero es cierto
que utilizar está pau puede hacer que el
cálculo sea más rápido entonces pues
vamos a usar pau tenemos que multiplicar
3x + 2
5 x menos 7 y lo que nos dice nuestra
buena amiga
pau es que tenemos que multiplicar
primero los primeros términos de cada
paréntesis gay este es el primer término
de este paréntesis y lo tenemos que
multiplicar por el primer término de
este otro paréntesis entonces aquí
tenemos 3x x 5x y después
pau nos dice que tenemos que multiplicar
los términos de afuera de los dos
paréntesis gay
este es un término de afuera porque está
en el extremo izquierdo y este con todo
y su signo menos es un término de afuera
porque está en el extremo derecho y
entonces tenemos que sumarle 3x x menos
7 y ahora pau dice que tenemos que
multiplicar los términos de adentro
estos son los términos de adentro
entonces sumamos 2
5x y finalmente pau dice que
multipliquemos los últimos términos de
cada paréntesis porque ahí tenemos que
multiplicar este término con este
término entonces sumamos 2 x menos 7
porque ya con pago estamos verificando
que hayamos multiplicado cada uno de
estos términos de este paréntesis por
cada uno de los términos de este otro
paréntesis lo que tenemos que poner en
algún punto 3 x x 5 x está por aquí y 13
x por menos 7 que está por aquí y
también no se nos puede olvidar poner 2
x 5 x que está aquí y 2 x menos 7 que
está por acá y ahora sí ya que tenemos
el desarrollo de esta multiplicación de
dos binomios vamos a simplificar la 3x
por 5x nos queda 15 x cuadrada
15 x nada más 13 x x menos 7 entonces es
3 por menos 7 menos 21 por x menos 21
por x y por aquí tenemos 2 x 5 x x que
es 10 x y finalmente 2 x menos 7 que es
menos 14
y aquí tenemos dos términos que tienen
una sola equis así es que los tenemos
que agrupar y nos queda 10 x menos 21 x
eso es menos 11 x así es que esta
multiplicación de dos binomios nos queda
tal cual como 15 x cuadrada menos 11 x
menos 14 ok este es el resultado de
multiplicar estos dos binomios
esto lo hicimos siguiendo todo lo que
nos dice pau sin embargo también lo
podemos hacer utilizando dos veces la
propiedad distributiva a ver acuérdense
cuál es la propiedad distributiva la
propiedad distributiva nos dice que si
tenemos aquí un paréntesis de nace y lo
multiplicamos por a esto de aquí es
igual a x b por b más a porsche a por c
y vamos a usarlo lo que quiero mostrarte
es que al utilizar dos veces la
propiedad distributiva al multiplicar
estos dos binomios nos queda exactamente
lo mismo que si seguimos todo lo que
dice pago aunque entonces voy a volver a
escribir aquí el problema tenemos que
multiplicar 3x + 2
5 x menos 7 y entonces lo que vamos a
hacer es utilizar la propiedad
distributiva pensando en que todo este
paréntesis
es esta de aquí de la propiedad
distributiva y entonces vamos a
multiplicar todo este paréntesis por 3x
y después multiplicar todo este
paréntesis por este 2 de aquí y entonces
lo que nos queda es 3x
5 x menos 7 + 2 x 5 x menos 7 y ahora lo
que vamos a hacer es volver a utilizar
la propiedad distributiva pero con cada
uno de estos paréntesis que hay vamos a
multiplicar este 3x por el 5x y a eso le
tenemos que sumar 13 x x menos 7 y ya
terminamos de usar la propiedad
distributiva con este paréntesis así es
que vamos a usarla en este paréntesis y
aquí tenemos que multiplicar el 2 por el
5x y sumarle lo que nos quede de
multiplicar el 2 por menos 7 lo que
veamos que nos queda
3 x x 5 x eso es 15 x cuadrada y ahora 3
x x menos 73 x menos 7 menos 21 o sea
menos 21
y de este lado tenemos 2 x 5 x o sea 10
x y finalmente 2 x menos 7 o sea menos
14 y listo ya desarrollamos esta
multiplicación usando dos veces la
propiedad distributiva y lo que nos
queda es exactamente lo mismo que nos
había quedado por aquí usando todo lo
que nos dice pau aunque entonces si
alguna vez no te acuerdas de qué es lo
que nos dice pau puedes simplemente
utilizar la propiedad distributiva dos
veces y llegas exactamente al mismo
resultado